das Wort Frühjahr ist Offensive ist
schon gefallen dazu gibt es auch viele
Fragen Eduard Kuhn fragt haben die leaks
einen Einfluss darauf ob die Offensive
noch im April stattfinden kann
also April würde ich sagen ist es
ausbildungstechnischen Gründen schon ist
ja unwahrscheinlich dass sie noch
stattfindet und das zweite aus Wetter
Wetter Sicht also jetzt ist sozusagen
unter Anführungszeichen oder es
gab es recht feuchtes Wetter ist ist am
komplizieren das zweite ist natürlich
viele westliche Waffensysteme bekommen
da waren die Einzel die Zug die Kompanie
Ausbildung im Westen des abgeschlossen
ist werden die Bataillone und diese
speziellen sturmbrigaden
zusammengestellt in der Ukraine die
müssen noch verbandstraining absolvieren
bis sie sozusagen eingeschweißtet
Verbände sind und sich aneinander
gewöhnt haben bis man unterschiedliche
Waffensysteme von unterschiedlichen
Geber Nationen auch aufeinander
einspielt und erst dann werden diese
privaten angriffsbereit das wird sowieso
bis meine Dauer
das zweite ist ihnen Dokumenten wird
über diese Gegend Offensive relativ
wenig gesagt das was an Kräften bereits
steht und was an Waffenlieferungen
gekommen ist das kann man Sekunde aus
der Presse auch zusammen
stellen wenn man auch beobachtet welche
ukrainischen Verbände nicht mehr
in den Front berichten vorkommen welche
also scheinbar aus der Front rausgezogen
sind dann kann man natürlich vermuten
dass diese Verbände an der
Gegenoffensive teilnehmen und per Outs
das sind dann auch die die zumindest
auch in der Größe in diesen Dokumenten
genannt werden also wie gesagt diese
Information hätte man sich eigentlich
aus öffentlichen der Dokumenten auch
zusammen suchen können und es ist ja
noch nichts über den Zeitpunkt und vor
allen Dingen auch nicht über die genaue
Angriffsrichtungen der ukrainischen
gegen Offensive in diesen Dokumenten
bekannt also zumindest in dem Teil von
denen wir wissen und das ist ja
eigentlich das was die Ukraine am
allermeisten geheim halten will wann und
wohin mit welcher Richtung und welchen
Angriffsziel sie eigentlich los schlagen
will
ich würde gerne mit einer letzten Frage
an Elma teven unseren USA Chaos von
hinten aus dem Stream verabschieden
immer letzte Frage an dich was ist deine
Einschätzung kommt dann noch mehr
also es ist nicht auszuschließen weil
wir wissen aus dem jetzt vorhandenen
Material das da Lücken drin sind wo es
eigentlich Sinn macht dass da noch mehr
sein könnte ich will aber zum Thema
Nebelkerzen auch noch mal klar sagen aus
amerikanischer Sicht macht das überhaupt
keinen Sinn weil der Flurschaden für die
USA jetzt schon riesig ist nicht nur das
verbündete sich aufregen nicht nur dass
es möglicherweise auch Einfluss auf das
Kriegsgeschehen hat nicht nur dass man
selber ja unter Druck gerät politisch
dadurch weil ganz klar muss man ja
fragen wie kann man so naiv und so
leichtsinnig sein solches streng geheime
Material irgendwie per Papier
gewissermaßen so zu verteilen das ist
dann am Ende einfach mal über so eine
Plattform verbreitet werden kann und
wenn es am Ende auch nur irgendjemand
gefunden hat der sich cool dabei vorkam
und sich keine größeren Gedanken darüber
gemacht hat aber vielleicht war es auch
gezielt jemand der tatsächlich allen
Beteiligten schaden wollte unmittelbar
da kann man viel spekulieren wer das
sein könnte also hier ist jedenfalls die
Sorge groß in der US-Regierung und eben
in Washington im Pentagon und im
Justizministerium wo das herkommt könnte
noch mehr sein und man will natürlich um
jeden Preis verhindern dass diese
Dokumente einfach mal so wieder
auftauchen und erst recht will man
verhindern dass sie dann Tage vielleicht
wochenlang in den Netzwerken geteilt
werden und zur Verfügung stehen um damit
möglicherweise auch weiter
Desinformationen zu betreiben
dann sage ich an dieser Stelle vielen
Dank Elmar the wir sind in diesem Fall
nach Belfast danke dass du bei uns im
Stream dabei warst
tja Herr gressel MRT Wissen hat es jetzt
ausgeführt es gibt viele denen diese
Veröffentlichungen Schaden anders herum
gefragt
Qi Bono wer hat denn was von diesen
Veröffentlichungen
ist eine gute Frage
sie stiften auf jeden Fall Verwirrung im
Westen da kann man natürlich annehmen
das sozusagen das Russland zu einem
gewissen Teil nützt natürlich
wenn es ein reinrussisches Lied wäre
würden wahrscheinlich seine Vorbereitung
wie wir es ja in den vergangenen Tagen
auch gesehen werden das Dokumente
nachträglich verfälscht worden im Wald
stärkerem Ausmaß
vorhanden sein das heißt hier sind
zurzeit würde ich sozusagen mit der
Frage cool Bruno die mal hinten
anstellen das sind noch viel zu viele
Eckpunkte dieses ganzen Geschehens noch
umkehrt
es kann also jetzt sag mal ganz böse
gesagt viele diese Dinge also entweder
es war jemand der sich cool vorkommt
viele Dinge
Geheimnis verräte etc passieren aber
auch aus inner bürokratischen
Flüssigkeiten dass sich Leute bei
Beförderungen bei anderen Dingen
übergangen sehen und dann aus ganz
persönlichen Motiven Organisationen
Schaden zufügen
oder oder ein Vorgesetzten an sich im
rechnen wollen alle diese Dinge die die
für uns aus objektiver Sicht komplett
lächerlich sind die spielen dann bei so
einer individuellen Motivation von
Leuten an die Öffentlichkeit mit
gewissen Dingen zu gehen oder
Informationen einen anderen Land oder
einem anderen Geheimdienst anzuvertrauen
eine erhebliche Rolle und all das wissen
wir zurzeit noch nicht und deshalb ist
es da würde ich mich dann nicht an
Spekulationen beteiligen kommen wir noch
mal auf die Auswirkungen auf die Ukraine
zurück an die MAC fragt welchen Einfluss
haben die Daten auf den Kriegsverlauf
verschlechtert sich die Situation der
Ukraine dadurch
also unmittelbar würde ich eher sagen
nein weil eben viele dieser Dinge
bekannt und berechenbar sind mittelbar
ist es natürlich auch ein schlechtes
Zeichen also das erste ist es wurde mal
eine gewisse Hybris aufgedeckt von dem
man natürlich auch da gab es Interviews
schauen da gab es schon Artikel auch in
der amerikanischen Presse dass die
beiden Administrationen öffentlich sich
sozusagen zu einem entschlossen eine
Hilfe der Ukraine bekennt also dass also
das sozusagen
dann auch im
militärischen Unterstützungsbereich und
wirklich umsetzen
würde aufgeworfen und da braucht
natürlich Russland schon stark her und
sagt
dass die Unterstützung im Westen die ist
nicht so unumstoßbar wie hier getan wird
vielleicht müssen wir einfach hier noch
Zahn zulegen oder wir müssen das noch
ein zwei Jahre aussetzen dann schaut das
anders aus das zweite ist eben dass man
wenn man wenig oder keine Informationen
hat was ein ukrainischen
munitionsbestand ist was am ukrainischen
Kräfte Dispositiv da ist und wenn man im
russischen geheimdienstapparaten das
auch eine alte russische Sitte den Feind
immer maßlos überschätzt indem man jede
jedes Gerücht dass man irgendwo
aufschnappt von Waffenlieferungen sofort
für bare Münze hält und sofort für
umgesetzt hält
dass man sich da sozusagen irgendwann
selbst abschreckt indem man den Gegner
für größer und mächtiger hält also
eigentlich ist dass man natürlich jetzt
durch diese Folien dann eher wieder
Richtung Tatsachen korrigiert wurde und
dann sich natürlich in einem langen
abnutzungskrieg schon
ausrechnet den auch über lange Sicht
gewinnen zu können wenn man das was an
ukrainischen Potenzial noch da ist
Matten wird können und das könnte der
Ukraine über den Sommer vor allen Dingen
sollte diese Gegend Offensive eben nicht
zu einem durchschlagenden Erfolg werden
durchaus noch stark zu Schaden kommen
sagt der militär-experte und
Politikwissenschaftler Gustav gräßel
vielen Dank von mir vielen Dank auch von
vielen Userinnen und Usern die sehr
dankbar sind für ihre Einschätzungen zum
Lage in der Ukraine und auch zu
Einschätzung der Pentagon liegt